This is 99% Invisible. I am Roman Mars. Happy New Year, beautiful nerds. It is now the impossibly futuristic-sounding 2025, and we are ringing in the new year with our 20th edition of mini-stories, featuring tales about Cold War neon signs, Japanese fire escapes, the marvels of Smello-vision,, but first we must wake up from our holiday slumber. Brace yourselves. I live in a house with seven other people. I'm going to let that sink in for a second. That is a lot of humans under one roof with a lot of different schedules, which means a lot of alarms going off anywhere from 6 a.m. to 10 a.m. There's the one that's like, but it goes for like an hour because it doesn't actually wake anyone up.
This is 99% Invisible. I am Roman Mars. Happy New Year, beautiful nerds. It is now the impossibly futuristic-sounding 2025, and we are ringing in the new year with our 20th edition of mini-stories, featuring tales about Cold War neon signs, Japanese fire escapes, the marvels of Smello-vision,, but first we must wake up from our holiday slumber. Brace yourselves. I live in a house with seven other people. I'm going to let that sink in for a second. That is a lot of humans under one roof with a lot of different schedules, which means a lot of alarms going off anywhere from 6 a.m. to 10 a.m. There's the one that's like, but it goes for like an hour because it doesn't actually wake anyone up.|||这里是“99%隐形”。我是罗曼·马尔斯。美丽的书呆子们，新年快乐。现在是听起来无比科幻的2025年，我们迎来了第20期迷你故事专场，本期节目包括关于冷战霓虹灯、日本逃生通道以及气味电影奇观的故事，但首先我们得从假期的沉睡中醒过来。做好心理准备。我和其他七个人住在一个屋檐下。我让大家消化一下这个事实。这意味着在一个屋檐下住着大量的人，他们的作息时间各不相同，也就是说，从早上6点到10点，会有各种各样的闹钟此起彼伏。其中有一个闹钟是这样的，但它会响上整整一个小时，因为它根本叫不醒任何人。
And then the one that really, really gets me is the duck. Now everyone has their own way of waking up. Personally, I don't really need an alarm because the fear, dread, and obligation of middle age keeps my consciousness right at the edge of alert at all times. But in my house, this morning chorus of quacks and bird songs exists because almost everyone sets their alarms early. Often, much earlier than they actually need to get up. And that's because they are building in time
And then the one that really, really gets me is the duck. Now everyone has their own way of waking up. Personally, I don't really need an alarm because the fear, dread, and obligation of middle age keeps my consciousness right at the edge of alert at all times. But in my house, this morning chorus of quacks and bird songs exists because almost everyone sets their alarms early. Often, much earlier than they actually need to get up. And that's because they are building in time|||然后那个真正让我抓狂的是鸭子叫声的闹钟。每个人都有自己的起床方式。就我个人而言，我其实不需要闹钟，因为中年带来的恐惧、担忧和责任感让我的意识时刻保持在警惕的边缘。但在我家，这种清晨的鸭叫声和鸟鸣声交织成的合唱之所以存在，是因为几乎每个人都把闹钟设得很早。通常比他们实际需要起床的时间要早得多。这是因为他们在预留时间。
to abuse the worst feature of their alarm. A feature so cursed and diabolical, it defeats the very purpose of any alarm. I'm talking of course about the snooze button. The snooze button is a bad solution to a conundrum that's existed for millennia. People need to sleep, but they also have things to do. In ancient Greece, Plato jolted himself out of bed with a system where a set amount of water slowly dripped into an airtight pot
to abuse the worst feature of their alarm. A feature so cursed and diabolical, it defeats the very purpose of any alarm. I'm talking of course about the snooze button. The snooze button is a bad solution to a conundrum that's existed for millennia. People need to sleep, but they also have things to do. In ancient Greece, Plato jolted himself out of bed with a system where a set amount of water slowly dripped into an airtight pot|||来滥用闹钟最糟糕的功能。这个功能如此遭人诅咒、极其邪恶，以至于违背了任何闹钟的初衷. 我说的当然是贪睡按钮（Snooze）。贪睡按钮是对困扰了人类数千年的难题的一个糟糕的解决方案。人们需要睡觉，但他们也有事情要做。在古希腊，柏拉图通过这样一个系统让自己从床上惊醒：让定量的水缓慢滴入一个密封的罐子里。
until the pressure was so high it would let out a piercing sound, kind of like a teapot. And during the Industrial Revolution, some towns had gigantic whistles which summoned workers to the factory. Around the same time, whole job existed for people who would go around knocking on doors and windows to wake people up. But once the alarm clock entered the household with sounds like this... and this... a backlash was inevitable. And this? A backlash was inevitable.
until the pressure was so high it would let out a piercing sound, kind of like a teapot. And during the Industrial Revolution, some towns had gigantic whistles which summoned workers to the factory. Around the same time, whole job existed for people who would go around knocking on doors and windows to wake people up. But once the alarm clock entered the household with sounds like this... and this... a backlash was inevitable. And this? A backlash was inevitable.|||直到气压高到会发出刺耳的声音，有点像茶壶。在工业革命期间，一些城镇有巨大的汽笛，用来召唤工人去工厂。大约在同一时期，还存在着一种专门四处敲门敲窗叫人起床的职业。但一旦闹钟进入千家万户，发出这样的声音……还有这样的声音……强烈的抵触情绪就在所难免了。还有这个？抵触情绪就在所难免了。
It was only a matter of time. You can sleep soundly depending upon the snooze alarm clock, the GE Telecom. It wakes you each morning and then lets you snooze. Continues to wake you just as you choose. In 1956, GE invented the world's first alarm clock with a snooze button. On top of the clock, there was a big ol' fat bar labeled snooze. That's S-N-O-O-Z. And it could not be missed. One smack of the clock and presto.
It was only a matter of time. You can sleep soundly depending upon the snooze alarm clock, the GE Telecom. It wakes you each morning and then lets you snooze. Continues to wake you just as you choose. In 1956, GE invented the world's first alarm clock with a snooze button. On top of the clock, there was a big ol' fat bar labeled snooze. That's S-N-O-O-Z. And it could not be missed. One smack of the clock and presto.|||这只是时间问题。有了带有贪睡功能的GE电信闹钟，你可以高枕无忧。它每天早晨叫醒你，然后让你继续打盹。按照你的选择继续叫醒你。1956年，通用电气（GE）发明了世界上第一款带有贪睡按钮的闹钟。在时钟的顶部，有一个大而粗的条状按钮，上面标着“snooze”。也就是 S-N-O-O-Z。而且它绝对不会被忽视。拍一下闹钟，然后，瞧。
You just bought yourself a little more sleep. The first snooze alarm clocks were built to let you snooze for 10 to 15 minutes. But mass production required some standardization. In the 1950s, a double-digit snooze was too complicated to program into the gears of a clock at scale. So GE cut as close as they could with nine minutes. A nine-minute snooze was the choice.
You just bought yourself a little more sleep. The first snooze alarm clocks were built to let you snooze for 10 to 15 minutes. But mass production required some standardization. In the 1950s, a double-digit snooze was too complicated to program into the gears of a clock at scale. So GE cut as close as they could with nine minutes. A nine-minute snooze was the choice.|||你刚刚为自己多买了一会儿睡眠。第一代贪睡闹钟的设计是让你贪睡10到15分钟。但大规模生产需要一定的标准化。在20世纪50年代，两位数的贪睡时间对于大规模量产的时钟齿轮来说，编程过于复杂。因此，通用电气尽可能地将时间缩减到了9分钟。9分钟的贪睡时间就这样成为了最终的选择。
After a millennia of trying to get ourselves out of bed at a certain time-minute snooze was the choice. After millennia of trying to get ourselves out of bed at a certain time, the snooze alarm dared to ask, do you really have to get up right now? And across the country, people more or less said, no, I don't. The clock was a major hit and as technology improved, a few competitors ended up offering alternatives to the 9 minute snooze, like the West Clocks' Drowse alarm clock. Let's see now, do I want five minutes more sleep or ten? Five. The West Clocks' alarm clock gave people the option of snoozing two different amounts of time,
After a millennia of trying to get ourselves out of bed at a certain time-minute snooze was the choice. After millennia of trying to get ourselves out of bed at a certain time, the snooze alarm dared to ask, do you really have to get up right now? And across the country, people more or less said, no, I don't. The clock was a major hit and as technology improved, a few competitors ended up offering alternatives to the 9 minute snooze, like the West Clocks' Drowse alarm clock. Let's see now, do I want five minutes more sleep or ten? Five. The West Clocks' alarm clock gave people the option of snoozing two different amounts of time,|||经过数千年试图让自己在某个特定时间起床的努力——9分钟贪睡成了最佳选择。在经历了数千年试图让自己按时起床的挣扎之后，贪睡闹钟敢于发问：你真的非得现在就起床吗？全国各地的人们或多或少都回答说：不，我不用。这款时钟大获成功，随着技术的进步，一些竞争对手最终推出了9分钟贪睡的替代方案，比如西时钟（Westclox）的打盹闹钟。让我想想，我是想要多睡五分钟还是十分钟？五分钟。西时钟的闹钟让人们可以选择两种不同的打盹时间。
depending on if you hit the drowse button on the left side or the right side. Gee, I could use 10 minutes this time. Man, you just can't oversleep with this new west clock. But the drows button didn't have that sweet, sweet simplicity. Nobody wants to wake up and think about how much longer they want to sleep. People just want to sleep more. And the snooze button gave us that. Or at least that's what we thought. Despite the fact that many of our phones are still factory preset to snooze for nine minutes,
depending on if you hit the drowse button on the left side or the right side. Gee, I could use 10 minutes this time. Man, you just can't oversleep with this new west clock. But the drows button didn't have that sweet, sweet simplicity. Nobody wants to wake up and think about how much longer they want to sleep. People just want to sleep more. And the snooze button gave us that. Or at least that's what we thought. Despite the fact that many of our phones are still factory preset to snooze for nine minutes,|||这取决于你按下的是左侧还是右侧的打盹按钮。天哪，这次我需要10分钟。天呐，有了这款新的西时钟，你绝对不会睡过头。但打盹按钮却没有那种美妙而纯粹的简单感。没有人愿意在醒来时还要思考自己到底想多睡多久。人们只是想多睡一会儿。而贪睡按钮满足了我们的这一愿望。或者至少我们当时是这么认为的。尽管事实上，我们的许多手机出厂时仍然默认贪睡时间为九分钟。
today we all know deep down that the snooze button doesn't really give us meaningful sleep. And it also doesn't let us rise. Instead, it catches us at our weakest moment when we are least capable of making decisions, when it's far easier to slap a button than to put two feet on the ground. In the end, the key to waking up might just rest in not giving yourself any other options. And the key to more sleep? Well, let me know when someone figures that out.
today we all know deep down that the snooze button doesn't really give us meaningful sleep. And it also doesn't let us rise. Instead, it catches us at our weakest moment when we are least capable of making decisions, when it's far easier to slap a button than to put two feet on the ground. In the end, the key to waking up might just rest in not giving yourself any other options. And the key to more sleep? Well, let me know when someone figures that out.|||但如今我们心知肚明，贪睡按钮并不能真正给我们带来有意义的睡眠。它也没能让我们真正起床。相反，它在我们最虚弱、最没有能力做出决定的时刻抓住了我们——此时拍一下按钮比双脚着地要容易得多。归根结底，醒来的关键也许就在于不给自己留任何其他选择。至于如何获得更多睡眠的关键？好吧，等有人研究出来的时候告诉我一声。
I'm here with 99PI editor Kelly Prime for a rare appearance on mic. So Kelly, what do you have for me today? Hi Roman. So I want you to imagine this very classic Americana neon scene. OK. So like if you imagine pictures of Broadway or vintage Las Vegas, like the street just lit up with signs sort of competing for your attention.
I'm here with 99PI editor Kelly Prime for a rare appearance on mic. So Kelly, what do you have for me today? Hi Roman. So I want you to imagine this very classic Americana neon scene. OK. So like if you imagine pictures of Broadway or vintage Las Vegas, like the street just lit up with signs sort of competing for your attention.|||我和99PI的编辑凯利·普莱姆（Kelly Prime）一起，她罕见地在节目中出镜。凯利，你今天给我带来了什么？嗨，罗曼。我想让你想象一个非常经典的美国风情霓虹灯场景。好的。如果你想象一下百老汇或复古拉斯维加斯的照片，就像街道上亮起各种招牌，它们似乎在争夺你的注意力。
Can you picture that? Absolutely, I can picture that. OK, great, because that's not what I'm talking about. Okay, well, I'll erase that from my mind, okay. That's the neon that you and I are probably more familiar with, but I want to tell you a story about a different neon aesthetic.
Can you picture that? Absolutely, I can picture that. OK, great, because that's not what I'm talking about. Okay, well, I'll erase that from my mind, okay. That's the neon that you and I are probably more familiar with, but I want to tell you a story about a different neon aesthetic.|||你能想象到那个画面吗？当然，我能想象到。好的，太棒了，因为这并不是我要谈论的。好吧，那我把它从脑子里删掉，好吗。那是你和我可能都更熟悉的霓虹灯，但我今天要给你讲一个关于另一种霓虹灯美学的故事。
It's one that was created in the Eastern Bloc right in the middle of the Cold War. And they basically took that flashy commercial Americana style of neon and they twisted it to make this new socialist style that's completely unique to this specific place at this specific moment of history. Okay, tell me more about it. So the story starts in the mid 50s,
It's one that was created in the Eastern Bloc right in the middle of the Cold War. And they basically took that flashy commercial Americana style of neon and they twisted it to make this new socialist style that's completely unique to this specific place at this specific moment of history. Okay, tell me more about it. So the story starts in the mid 50s,|||这种美学诞生于正处于冷战高潮时期的东欧阵营。他们基本上借鉴了那种浮华的美国商业风格的霓虹灯，并将其扭曲，创造出了一种全新的社会主义风格，这种风格完全是历史特定时刻特定地点的独特产物。好的，多跟我讲讲。故事要从50年代中期说起。
about a decade into communism in the Eastern Bloc. At this point, people were starting to push back, to rebel. And so Soviet leaders got together and they were like, we have to work out a plan to quell some of this political unrest. And their plan was basically neon. It was called neonization was the state sponsored program. Okay I'm in tell me more. Okay neonization was a government program meant to push the idea of a brighter future. Since this is your first
about a decade into communism in the Eastern Bloc. At this point, people were starting to push back, to rebel. And so Soviet leaders got together and they were like, we have to work out a plan to quell some of this political unrest. And their plan was basically neon. It was called neonization was the state sponsored program. Okay I'm in tell me more. Okay neonization was a government program meant to push the idea of a brighter future. Since this is your first|||那时东欧阵营的共产主义已经实行了大约十年。此时，人们开始反抗，开始叛逆。于是苏联领导人聚在一起，他们觉得：我们必须制定一个计划来平息这些政治动乱。而他们的计划基本上就是霓虹灯。这个由国家赞助的项目被称为“霓虹化”（neonization）。好吧，我入坑了，多讲点。好的，“霓虹化”是一项旨在推销“更光明未来”理念的政府计划。既然这是你第一次。
time recording with me I will allow you that one once, but another one of those, and I'm pulling the plug. We'll see. The concept was like, okay, things are bleak, we get that, but shh, don't even worry about it. Look at these lights! So what they decided to do was change the landscape, turn things around, brighten up everything.
time recording with me I will allow you that one once, but another one of those, and I'm pulling the plug. We'll see. The concept was like, okay, things are bleak, we get that, but shh, don't even worry about it. Look at these lights! So what they decided to do was change the landscape, turn things around, brighten up everything.|||和我一起录音，我这次就原谅你这一次，但如果再来一次，我就要拔掉电源了。走着瞧吧。这个概念就像是：好吧，局势很黯淡，我们懂的，但是嘘，别担心。看这些灯光！所以他们决定做的是改变景观，扭转局势，让一切都亮起来。
That's David Hill, he's the director of the NEON Museum in Warsaw, which is dedicated to documenting and preserving Cold War era NEON signs. The proponents certainly argued, this will placate the public, this will bamboozle them, this will make people happy again. So rather than provide things, you know, substantive things in their lives
That's David Hill, he's the director of the NEON Museum in Warsaw, which is dedicated to documenting and preserving Cold War era NEON signs. The proponents certainly argued, this will placate the public, this will bamboozle them, this will make people happy again. So rather than provide things, you know, substantive things in their lives|||说话的是大卫·希尔（David Hill），他是华沙霓虹灯博物馆（NEON Museum）的馆长，该博物馆致力于记录和保存冷战时期的霓虹灯招牌。支持者们当然争辩说：这会安抚公众，这会迷惑他们，这会让人民再次开心起来。因此，与其在生活中提供那些实质性的东西。
to actually make people happy, they just decided to put lights in front of them. Exactly. Yeah, great use of resources. Okay. Okay. And so why neon specifically? Why not murals or, you know, I don't know, anything else? So the thing is that Eastern Europe actually had a history with neon and this was especially true of Warsaw. So before World War II Warsaw had been just like another modern European capital with everything that entailed including bright shiny lights. It was a shimmering pearl it was very famous for its neon signs from 1926 onwards so it had this
to actually make people happy, they just decided to put lights in front of them. Exactly. Yeah, great use of resources. Okay. Okay. And so why neon specifically? Why not murals or, you know, I don't know, anything else? So the thing is that Eastern Europe actually had a history with neon and this was especially true of Warsaw. So before World War II Warsaw had been just like another modern European capital with everything that entailed including bright shiny lights. It was a shimmering pearl it was very famous for its neon signs from 1926 onwards so it had this|||来真正让人们快乐，他们干脆决定在人们面前摆上灯光。没错。资源利用得真好，太棒了。好吧。那么，为什么偏偏是霓虹灯呢？为什么不是壁画或者别的什么东西呢？事实是，东欧其实有着使用霓虹灯的历史，华沙尤其如此。在二战之前，华沙就像其他任何现代欧洲首都一样，拥有一切现代元素，包括明亮耀眼的灯光。它是一颗闪亮的明珠，自1926年起就以其霓虹灯招牌而闻名遐迩，所以它与霓虹灯有着这样的渊源。
connection to neon. But the war just basically destroyed all of them. As you can imagine, these very delicate glass tubes would not fare well in all the bombings that happened. But even though they were gone, people in Warsaw still had a really positive association with them. It really represented modernity and just generally prosperity, like before things were destroyed. So the socialist government knew that and they figured they could sort of leverage that association to foster goodwill towards the current regime. So the communist government came up with this plan to neonize the city to make everyone happy. So what's step one in this process? How do they start?
connection to neon. But the war just basically destroyed all of them. As you can imagine, these very delicate glass tubes would not fare well in all the bombings that happened. But even though they were gone, people in Warsaw still had a really positive association with them. It really represented modernity and just generally prosperity, like before things were destroyed. So the socialist government knew that and they figured they could sort of leverage that association to foster goodwill towards the current regime. So the communist government came up with this plan to neonize the city to make everyone happy. So what's step one in this process? How do they start?|||联系。但战争几乎摧毁了所有这些霓虹灯。你可以想象，这些极其脆弱的玻璃管在经历的所有轰炸中根本无法幸存。但尽管它们消失了，华沙人民对它们仍然有着非常积极的联想。霓虹灯真正代表了现代性和普遍的繁荣，就像一切被毁灭之前那样。因此，社会主义政府深谙这一点，他们认为可以利用这种联想来培养民众对现政权的善意。于是，共产主义政府提出了这个将城市“霓虹化”以让每个人都快乐的计划。那么这个过程的第一步是什么？他们是如何开始的？
So one of the first things the government did was to hire some of the best artists in the nation. And some of these people actually were already talented neon artists and electricians. But many of them weren't. These were groundbreaking visual artists who were used to working on paper and canvas. They didn't necessarily
So one of the first things the government did was to hire some of the best artists in the nation. And some of these people actually were already talented neon artists and electricians. But many of them weren't. These were groundbreaking visual artists who were used to working on paper and canvas. They didn't necessarily|||因此，政府做的第一件事就是聘请国内最优秀的艺术家。这些人中有些其实已经是才华横溢的霓虹灯艺术家和电工。但许多人并不是。他们是开创性的视觉艺术家，习惯于在纸张和画布上创作。他们不一定。
have any pre-existing experience working with neon. So the only thing that was really limiting their imagination was the bounds of the material. They would just have a piece of cardboard and just draw lines all over it and then later realize, well, that's not really possible. We can't make that too zigzaggy or whatever the restrictions were. OK, so given that their imagination is wild and is unfettered by the constraints of neon, but there are actual physical constraints of building something in neon, what exactly did the artists end up making? I'm so glad you asked because I've been very into these since I discovered them.
have any pre-existing experience working with neon. So the only thing that was really limiting their imagination was the bounds of the material. They would just have a piece of cardboard and just draw lines all over it and then later realize, well, that's not really possible. We can't make that too zigzaggy or whatever the restrictions were. OK, so given that their imagination is wild and is unfettered by the constraints of neon, but there are actual physical constraints of building something in neon, what exactly did the artists end up making? I'm so glad you asked because I've been very into these since I discovered them.|||有任何使用霓虹灯创作的既往经验。所以真正限制他们想象力的只有材料本身的局限。他们手里拿着一块硬纸板，在上面画满了线条，然后才意识到：嗯，这不太可能实现。我们不能把线条设计得太曲折，或者诸如此类的限制。好吧，既然他们的想象力天马行空，且不受霓虹灯材质的束缚，但用霓虹灯制作实物时又确实存在物理限制，艺术家们最终到底创作出了什么？很高兴你问起这个，因为自从我发现这些作品以来，我就一直非常着迷。
And I think the best way to go about it is just to show you some examples. So the first one I'm about to ask you to look at was made to decorate a flower shop. So just describe what you're seeing here. So I'm seeing very bright neon and it's a green kind of vine, lots of flowers of a couple of different colors.
And I think the best way to go about it is just to show you some examples. So the first one I'm about to ask you to look at was made to decorate a flower shop. So just describe what you're seeing here. So I'm seeing very bright neon and it's a green kind of vine, lots of flowers of a couple of different colors.|||我觉得最好的方式就是直接给你看几个例子。我要让你看的第一个例子是用来装饰一家花店的。描述一下你在这里看到了什么。我看到非常明亮的霓虹灯，那是一种绿色的藤蔓，上面有许多不同颜色的花朵。
And the flower petals, like they're not uniform. It's a green kind of vine, lots of flowers of a couple of different colors. And the flower petals, like, they're not uniform. They're like, they're kind of, they're kind of scribbly. Exactly. They're like scribbly. It looks like a sketch pad, like someone has been doodling, but on an entire building with neon. This was designed by a graphic artist, Zofia Kostetska, Malchowkowska.
And the flower petals, like they're not uniform. It's a green kind of vine, lots of flowers of a couple of different colors. And the flower petals, like, they're not uniform. They're like, they're kind of, they're kind of scribbly. Exactly. They're like scribbly. It looks like a sketch pad, like someone has been doodling, but on an entire building with neon. This was designed by a graphic artist, Zofia Kostetska, Malchowkowska.|||花瓣看起来……它们不是统一的。那是一种绿色的藤蔓，有很多不同颜色的花。花瓣好像……它们不是整齐划一的。它们看起来有点像是……有点像是随手涂鸦。没错。它们就像是涂鸦。看起来就像一本素描本，就像有人一直在涂鸦，只不过是用霓虹灯在一整栋建筑物上涂鸦。这是由平面艺术家佐菲娅·科斯特茨卡-马尔霍夫科夫斯卡（Zofia Kostetska-Małachowska）设计的。
So she created this as a young graphic designer for a pavilion that sold basically carnations and roses. Nothing fancy there, except the building was covered in butterflies and flowers and grass. It was enormous. We're talking 20, 30 meters. Oh yeah, so these are big. They're huge. These are huge. Okay. So they're not like a Budweiser sign hanging in the window of a bar. They are not that. 20, 30 meters. That's the hundred feet of squiggly flowers.
So she created this as a young graphic designer for a pavilion that sold basically carnations and roses. Nothing fancy there, except the building was covered in butterflies and flowers and grass. It was enormous. We're talking 20, 30 meters. Oh yeah, so these are big. They're huge. These are huge. Okay. So they're not like a Budweiser sign hanging in the window of a bar. They are not that. 20, 30 meters. That's the hundred feet of squiggly flowers.|||作为一名年轻的平面艺术家，她为这个主要出售康乃馨和玫瑰的展馆创作了这幅作品。里面没有什么特别fancy的东西，除了整栋建筑被蝴蝶、鲜花和青草所覆盖。它是巨大的。我们说的是20、30米长。哦，对，所以这些尺寸很大。它们非常巨大。这些都是庞然大物。好吧。所以它们不像挂在酒吧窗户上的百威啤酒招牌。它们完全不是那样的。20、30米长。那可是长达一百英尺的扭曲花朵。
That's amazing. It's crazy. Yeah. Okay. So the next one I want to show you is actually, the scale is not the same, but it is one of my favorites. It's a pink mermaid and she's holding up a sword and shield, which is like the mermaid with the sword and shield is the symbol of the city of Warsaw.
That's amazing. It's crazy. Yeah. Okay. So the next one I want to show you is actually, the scale is not the same, but it is one of my favorites. It's a pink mermaid and she's holding up a sword and shield, which is like the mermaid with the sword and shield is the symbol of the city of Warsaw.|||太惊人了。太疯狂了。是的。好的。我要给你看的下一个作品，虽然规模没那么大，但它是我最喜欢的作品之一。那是一只粉红色的美人鱼，她高举着一把剑和一面盾牌，手持剑和盾的美人鱼正是华沙市的象征。
And she's hovering over an open book. Wherever you saw this beautiful pink mermaid sitting on an open book, she would denote your public library. So Biblioteca Publicina. Wonderful. So you would see the symbol all over the place in Warsaw. That's so cool. This thing is beautiful.
And she's hovering over an open book. Wherever you saw this beautiful pink mermaid sitting on an open book, she would denote your public library. So Biblioteca Publicina. Wonderful. So you would see the symbol all over the place in Warsaw. That's so cool. This thing is beautiful.|||她悬浮在一本翻开的书上方。无论你在哪里看到这只美丽粉红美人鱼坐在翻开的书上，她就代表着你的公共图书馆。也就是公共图书馆（Biblioteca Publicina）。太棒了。所以在华沙到处都能看到这个标志。太酷了。这个东西真漂亮。
It's hard to imagine neon over municipal buildings. Exactly. I was in, I was in Socrates, New York, like literally yesterday, and there was a pink neon framing of this old industrial bridge. And I was just like mesmerized by that thing. And just that sort of juxtaposition of neon and just kind of pretty mundane municipal design and decay was lovely.
It's hard to imagine neon over municipal buildings. Exactly. I was in, I was in Socrates, New York, like literally yesterday, and there was a pink neon framing of this old industrial bridge. And I was just like mesmerized by that thing. And just that sort of juxtaposition of neon and just kind of pretty mundane municipal design and decay was lovely.|||很难想象市政建筑上会有霓虹灯。确实如此。我昨天还在纽约苏格拉底雕塑公园，那里有一座老旧工业桥梁，上面装饰着粉红色的霓虹灯边框。我当时就被那个东西迷住了。霓虹灯与那种相当平淡的市政设计和残破景象并置在一起，感觉非常可爱。
It was a revelation to me, I loved it. Yeah, I want more of that. And that was very much the thing here, like very much the thing. So by the late 60s, Warsaw had hundreds of thousands of these signs across the city. But what's really striking to me is the fact that all of these neon signs had this cohesiveness to them. If you cast your mind to that, again, American scene of a street covered in neon, what you're going to see is a big sort of mishmash of color.
It was a revelation to me, I loved it. Yeah, I want more of that. And that was very much the thing here, like very much the thing. So by the late 60s, Warsaw had hundreds of thousands of these signs across the city. But what's really striking to me is the fact that all of these neon signs had this cohesiveness to them. If you cast your mind to that, again, American scene of a street covered in neon, what you're going to see is a big sort of mishmash of color.|||对我来说这是一个启示，我太喜欢了。是的，我想看到更多这样的东西。这里的情况也完全是这样，真的就是这样。因此，到20世纪60年代末，华沙全市有数十万个这样的霓虹灯招牌。但真正让我震惊的是，所有这些霓虹灯招牌都具有一种内在的凝聚力。如果你再次回想美国那种霓虹灯密布的街道场景，你看到的将会是各种色彩的大杂烩。
But in Poland, that was not at all the case. We're looking at something as a very well thought out coherent project and I think that delivered a slightly different aesthetic, a different feeling. As if, my god, the city is a city of neon, it's a city of light and it all seems to work together. It all seems to be harmonious. And a big reason for that is the fact that this neonization process was run by the state. There was actually a central body that commissioned and signed off on every single sign. You'd think they'd have better things to do. Yeah, no, I guess not.
But in Poland, that was not at all the case. We're looking at something as a very well thought out coherent project and I think that delivered a slightly different aesthetic, a different feeling. As if, my god, the city is a city of neon, it's a city of light and it all seems to work together. It all seems to be harmonious. And a big reason for that is the fact that this neonization process was run by the state. There was actually a central body that commissioned and signed off on every single sign. You'd think they'd have better things to do. Yeah, no, I guess not.|||但在波兰，情况完全不是这样。我们看到的是一个经过深思熟虑、具有连贯性的项目，我认为这带来了一种截然不同的美学和感受。就好像，天哪，这座城市是一座霓虹之城，是一座光之城，一切似乎都协同工作。一切看起来都是那么和谐。这其中很大一部分原因是，这个“霓虹化”过程是由国家主导的。实际上有一个中央机构负责委托并审批每一个招牌。你可能会觉得他们应该有更重要的事情要做。是的，不，我想并没有。
And all these signs were specifically designed to complement each other, so no one piece was approved unless it fit into the style of the whole. You can see how seriously the authorities took this in that eventually the chief city architect's title was abolished and it became the chief city graphic designer. So there was less importance on architecture and more placed on neonization and the urban aesthetic, the design. So after all this neonization, Warsaw is covered in neon. But did their ultimate goal actually bear fruit? I mean, were people actually happier?
And all these signs were specifically designed to complement each other, so no one piece was approved unless it fit into the style of the whole. You can see how seriously the authorities took this in that eventually the chief city architect's title was abolished and it became the chief city graphic designer. So there was less importance on architecture and more placed on neonization and the urban aesthetic, the design. So after all this neonization, Warsaw is covered in neon. But did their ultimate goal actually bear fruit? I mean, were people actually happier?|||所有这些招牌都是经过专门设计以相互辉映的，因此，只有符合整体风格的招牌才会获得批准。从当局最终取消了总城市建筑师的头衔并将其改为总城市平面设计师这一点，可以看出他们对此有多么严肃认真。因此，人们对建筑本身的重视程度降低了，转而更加重视“霓虹化”以及城市美学和设计。经过如此大规模的“霓虹化”改造后，华沙到处都是霓虹灯。但他们的最终目标真的见效了吗？我是说，人们真的更快乐了吗？
Did they convince the people of Poland that everything was okay? Well, first of all, it's hard to say how people in Poland felt about neonization in general. Certainly the signs were really beautiful and it's easy to appreciate their beauty, but it's also safe to say that this tricked exactly no one into thinking that, you know, life under communism was really great.
Did they convince the people of Poland that everything was okay? Well, first of all, it's hard to say how people in Poland felt about neonization in general. Certainly the signs were really beautiful and it's easy to appreciate their beauty, but it's also safe to say that this tricked exactly no one into thinking that, you5 know, life under communism was really great.|||他们是否让波兰人民相信一切都好呢？首先，很难说波兰人民对“霓虹化”总体上有什么感受。当然，这些招牌确实很漂亮，也很容易欣赏它们的美，但也可以肯定地说，这绝对没有欺骗任何人去认为，你知道的，共产主义下的生活真的很美好。
By the early 80s, things had in fact gotten so bad that the socialist government instituted martial law. And that really took a toll on Warsaw's neon. These neon signs were switched off. The authorities said, well, you don't need them. You know, you're under house arrest. Why would you want to go out in the evening? So they were basically switched off and they were really the first rather obvious victims of this new political revolution that brought in democracy.
By the early 80s, things had in fact gotten so bad that the socialist government instituted martial law. And that really took a toll on Warsaw's neon. These neon signs were switched off. The authorities said, well, you don't need them. You know, you're under house arrest. Why would you want to go out in the evening? So they were basically switched off and they were really the first rather obvious victims of this new political revolution that brought in democracy.|||到了20世纪80年代初，局势实际上已经恶化到社会主义政府实施军事管制的程度。这给华沙的霓虹灯带来了沉重的打击。这些霓虹灯被关掉了。当局说，好吧，你们不需要它们。你知道的，你们都被软禁在家。为什么还要在晚上出门呢？所以它们基本上都被关闭了，它们确实成为了这场带来民主的新政治革命的最初、相当明显的牺牲品。
And what happened next, you probably know, communism in the Eastern Bloc didn't last. In 1989, Poland's communist state was officially replaced by a new democratic government. And when that happened, that was really the end for Warsaw's neons. The new democratic Polish government looked at the symbols from this period of occupation as they saw it, and neon was the obvious target. And so they set about destroying as many neon signs as they could in what they called the
And what happened next, you probably know, communism in the Eastern Bloc didn't last. In 1989, Poland's communist state was officially replaced by a new democratic government. And when that happened, that was really the end for Warsaw's neons. The new democratic Polish government looked at the symbols from this period of occupation as they saw it, and neon was the obvious target. And so they set about destroying as many neon signs as they could in what they called the|||接下来发生的事情你可能也知道了，东欧阵营的共产主义并没有持续下去。1989年，波兰的共产主义政权正式被一个新的民主政府所取代。当这一切发生时，华沙的霓虹灯也就真正走到了尽头。波兰新民主政府将那个占领时期的象征（在他们看来）视作眼中钉，而霓虹灯自然成为了首要目标。于是，他们着手摧毁尽可能多的霓虹灯招牌，并给这个行动起了一个名字叫作：
Great Recycling Scheme, rather quaintly. And we lost so many, so many neons. Wow, the Great Recycling Scheme is quite a euphemism. Yeah, people were paid to go out into the city, find the neon signs and destroy them. So are any of the original signs left up? I mean, those pictures you showed me, are those contemporary or were all the signs destroyed?
Great Recycling Scheme, rather quaintly. And we lost so many, so many neons. Wow, the Great Recycling Scheme is quite a euphemism. Yeah, people were paid to go out into the city, find the neon signs and destroy them. So are any of the original signs left up? I mean, those pictures you showed me, are those contemporary or were all the signs destroyed?|||“伟大的回收计划”，听起来还挺古雅的。我们失去了太多的霓虹灯。哇，“伟大的回收计划”真是一个绝妙的委婉说法。是的，人们拿钱去城市里寻找霓虹灯招牌并将其砸毁。那么，还有原汁原味的招牌保留下来吗？我是说，你给我看的那些照片是当代的，还是说所有的招牌都被摧毁了？
So those pictures I showed you are contemporary. Those are photos of some of the few signs that did manage to survive all this time. But most of Warsaw's neons were either broken or taken down. And eventually the remnants of neonization just kind of faded into the backdrop of the city rather than being what they once were, which is, you know, a focal point of it. But I will say that in the last 20 or so years, there has been renewed interest among the residents of Warsaw in those signs and their history.
So those pictures I showed you are contemporary. Those are photos of some of the few signs that did manage to survive all this time. But most of Warsaw's neons were either broken or taken down. And eventually the remnants of neonization just kind of faded into the backdrop of the city rather than being what they once were, which is, you know, a focal point of it. But I will say that in the last 20 or so years, there has been renewed interest among the residents of Warsaw in those signs and their history.|||我给你看的那些照片是当代的。那些照片记录的是少数历经沧桑幸存下来的霓虹灯招牌。但华沙大部分的霓虹灯要么被砸坏了，要么被拆除了。最终，“霓虹化”的残余渐渐淡入城市的背景之中，而不像过去那样成为城市的焦点。但我得说，在过去的20年左右里，华沙居民对这些招牌及其历史的兴趣又重新被点燃了。
I do have some really good news and that is that Warsaw is undergoing a bit of a renaissance. Neonization has returned. Today people come from around the world to see what's left of Warsaw's neons. And David says that there are now new neon signs all over Warsaw. And some of them are directly referencing the work of Poland's great neon artists. You see these fantastic places that young people hang out. And you look and you think, I've seen that before. That's a neon design by Jan Młodzki,
I do have some really good news and that is that Warsaw is undergoing a bit of a renaissance. Neonization has returned. Today people come from around the world to see what's left of Warsaw's neons. And David says that there are now new neon signs all over Warsaw. And some of them are directly referencing the work of Poland's great neon artists. You see these fantastic places that young people hang out. And you look and you think, I've seen that before. That's a neon design by Jan Młodzki,|||我确实有一个非常好的消息，那就是华沙正在经历某种复兴。“霓虹化”又回来了。今天，人们从世界各地赶来参观华沙残留的霓虹灯。大卫说，如今华沙到处都是新的霓虹灯招牌。其中一些直接借鉴了波兰伟大霓虹灯艺术家的作品。你看到年轻人经常光顾的这些绝佳场所。你看着看着就会想：我以前见过这个。那是扬·莫德基（Jan Młodzki）设计的霓虹灯。
this famous neonizer and Polish poster artist. And there it is on the streets of Warsaw, reinvented for the modern age, reinvented for the young people. Well, thank you, Kelly. Thanks, Roman. And if you'd like to see some examples of these Polish neon signs, we'll have some
this famous neonizer and Polish poster artist. And there it is on the streets of Warsaw, reinvented for the modern age, reinvented for the young people. Well, thank you, Kelly. Thanks, Roman. And if you'd like to see some examples of these Polish neon signs, we'll have some|||这位著名的霓虹灯设计师和波兰海报艺术家。它就这样出现在华沙的街头，为现代重新演绎，为年轻人重新演绎。谢谢你，凯利。谢谢你，罗曼。如果你想看一些这些波兰霓虹灯招牌的例子，我们将在。
pictures on the website. Coming up, our digital director Kurt Kohlstedt figures out how to escape from a burning building in Japan. News you can use. And our pal Gillian Jacobs talks to us about movies you can smell. That's after the break. We are back with digital director, Kurt Kohlstedt. Kurt, what do you have for us? Yeah, so I wanted to tell you about this small design element
pictures on the website. Coming up, our digital director Kurt Kohlstedt figures out how to escape from a burning building in Japan. News you can use. And our pal Gillian Jacobs talks to us about movies you can smell. That's after the break. We are back with digital director, Kurt Kohlstedt. Kurt, what do you have for us? Yeah, so I wanted to tell you about this small design element|||网站上放置一些照片。接下来，我们的数字总监库尔特·科尔施泰特（Kurt Kohlstedt）将为我们讲解如何在着火的日本建筑中逃生。这是对你有用的资讯。我们的朋友吉莉安·雅各布斯（Gillian Jacobs）将与我们聊聊可以闻到气味的电影。广告之后见。我们回来了，和数字总监库尔特·科尔施泰特在一起。库尔特，你给我们带来了什么？是的，我想跟你聊聊这个微小的设计元素。
that I first encountered in Tokyo. I was walking around and I started to notice these red stickers that were shaped like perfect equilateral triangles and stuck to the windows of a bunch of different buildings. Here's a picture to show you what I'm talking about. Okay, so let's see. Yes, it's a red triangle, the tip pointing down, and it's centered right in the middle
that I first encountered in Tokyo. I was walking around and I started to notice these red stickers that were shaped like perfect equilateral triangles and stuck to the windows of a bunch of different buildings. Here's a picture to show you what I'm talking about. Okay, so let's see. Yes, it's a red triangle, the tip pointing down, and it's centered right in the middle|||这是我在东京第一次遇到的。当时我在四处闲逛，开始注意到一些红色的贴纸，它们的形状是完美的正三角形，贴在许多不同建筑物的窗户上。这张照片展示了我在说什么。好的，让我看看。是的，这是一个红色的三角形，尖角朝下，正对着中间。
of every window that I see. Like it doesn't seem accidental or put on by the people, you know, haphazardly on the inside. Right, there's a certain consistency to it. There's like one upside down red triangle every couple of windows. And then, you know, once I noticed them, I started to see these stickers everywhere,
of every window that I see. Like it doesn't seem accidental or put on by the people, you know, haphazardly on the inside. Right, there's a certain consistency to it. There's like one upside down red triangle every couple of windows. And then, you know, once I noticed them, I started to see these stickers everywhere,|||我看过的每一扇窗户的正中央。这看起来不像是偶然的，也不是人们在里面随随便便贴上去的。没错，这有一定的规律性。每隔几扇窗户就有一个倒置的红色三角形。然后，你知道的，一旦我注意到了它们，我就开始到处都能看到这些贴纸。
not just in Tokyo, but then later in Osaka, in Kobe, in Kyoto. You know, now that I've seen these pictures, I have to admit, I didn't see these when I was in Japan. So what's up with all these stickers? So they're called Fire Department Access stickers. And you shouldn't feel too bad about missing them. It really helped that I had one smack dad in the middle of my first hotel room window in Tokyo.
not just in Tokyo, but then later in Osaka, in Kobe, in Kyoto. You know, now that I've seen these pictures, I have to admit, I didn't see these when I was in Japan. So what's up with all these stickers? So they're called Fire Department Access stickers. And you shouldn't feel too bad about missing them. It really helped that I had one smack dad in the middle of my first hotel room window in Tokyo.|||不仅在东京，后来在大阪、神户、京都也能看到。你看过这些照片后，我不得不承认，我在日本的时候并没有看到这些东西。那么这些贴纸到底是怎么回事？它们被称为“消防部门出入口贴纸”（Fire Department Access stickers）。你没注意到也不用觉得太糟糕。我在东京住的第一家酒店的窗户正中央就贴着一个，这确实帮了大忙。
So I did some research and I found out that in an emergency, the red triangles indicate to firefighters where to lean their ladders. And then on the inside, they have explanatory text that tells people in the building where they should go and expect to find rescue. Do the triangles indicate that the windows are somehow different or that they're just the gathering point of a rescuer meeting rescuee? Well, yeah, so I looked into that and some of what I read indicated that these windows could be opened more easily, like either by firefighters from the outside or people from the inside. And one account indicated that they might be built out of more breakable glass too, so that like you can shatter them in an emergency.
So I did some research and I found out that in an emergency, the red triangles indicate to firefighters where to lean their ladders. And then on the inside, they have explanatory text that tells people in the building where they should go and expect to find rescue. Do the triangles indicate that the windows are somehow different or that they're just the gathering point of a rescuer meeting rescuee? Well, yeah, so I looked into that and some of what I read indicated that these windows could be opened more easily, like either by firefighters from the outside or people from the inside. And one account indicated that they might be built out of more breakable glass too, so that like you can shatter them in an emergency.|||于是我做了一些研究，发现如果在紧急情况下，红色三角形向消防员指示了他们应该把云梯搭在什么地方。然后在内部，它们带有说明文字，告诉大楼里的人他们应该去哪里并期望在那里获得救援。三角形是否表明这些窗户在某种程度上有所不同，还是说它们只是救援人员与被救援人员会合的集合点？嗯，是的，我查阅了相关资料，我读到的一些内容表明，这些窗户可以更容易地打开，无论是消防员从外部打开，还是里面的人从内部打开。还有一种说法表明，它们可能是用更容易破碎的玻璃建造的，这样你就可以在紧急情况下将它们砸碎。
And then I noticed under my window in my hotel room that there was this metal stick which clearly wasn't there to open the window. And I got to wondering like, is that so that I can smash the window? And I confess I did not test the theory. And so I cannot confirm if that's why the stick was there. Well, regardless of whether these arrows are indicators of any structural or physical difference about these windows, this is a place where you can go to get out of the building in an emergency. Yeah, exactly. It's a meeting point.
And then I noticed under my window in my hotel room that there was this metal stick which clearly wasn't there to open the window. And I got to wondering like, is that so that I can smash the window? And I confess I did not test the theory. And so I cannot confirm if that's why the stick was there. Well, regardless of whether these arrows are indicators of any structural or physical difference about these windows, this is a place where you can go to get out of the building in an emergency. Yeah, exactly. It's a meeting point.|||然后我注意到我酒店房间的窗户下面有一根金属棒，这显然不是用来开窗的。我开始琢磨：这根棍子是让我用来砸窗户的吗？我承认我没有验证过这个推测。所以我无法确认这根棍子是不是为了这个目的而存在的。好吧，不管这些箭头是否指示了这些窗户在结构或物理上有任何不同，这都是一个在紧急情况下你可以前往以逃离大楼的地方。是的，完全正确。这是一个集合点。
I guess I'm just kind of surprised that I missed these stickers. Like, are they only on certain kinds of buildings, or are they just all kind of high up? Well, yeah, you're on the right track there. Height is the key determinant, because if you think about it, like smaller buildings, including houses that only have a story or two, obviously wouldn't need these at all. And on taller buildings, they'd only be needed within a certain height range because of course, if a window is too high to be reached by a firefighter ladder, it would be dark to encourage people to congregate there, frankly.
I guess I'm just kind of surprised that I missed these stickers. Like, are they only on certain kinds of buildings, or are they just all kind of high up? Well, yeah, you're on the right track there. Height is the key determinant, because if you think about it, like smaller buildings, including houses that only have a story or two, obviously wouldn't need these at all. And on taller buildings, they'd only be needed within a certain height range because of course, if a window is too high to be reached by a firefighter ladder, it would be dark to encourage people to congregate there, frankly.|||我只是有点惊讶我竟然漏掉了这些贴纸。比如，它们只贴在某些种类的建筑上，还是说它们都贴得比较高？嗯，对，你抓住了关键。高度是决定性因素，因为如果你想想看，比如较小的建筑，包括只有一两层的房屋，显然根本不需要这些。而在较高的建筑物上，它们也只在一定的高度范围内需要，因为当然了说实话，如果一扇窗户太高，消防云梯够不到，那聚在那里也就毫无意义了。
I see. There's only a narrow band where these are functional. They have to be high enough that you wouldn't just get out by yourself on the first floor or second floor, but low enough that it'd be possible for a firefighter's ladder to reach you. Yeah, exactly. And from the regulation accounts that I was reading, of course, in translation and secondary sources, it appears that it's about 100 feet where these things cap out. Okay. So that's the reason why I missed them.
I see. There's only a narrow band where these are functional. They have to be high enough that you wouldn't just get out by yourself on the first floor or second floor, but low enough that it'd be possible for a firefighter's ladder to reach you. Yeah, exactly. And from the regulation accounts that I was reading, of course, in translation and secondary sources, it appears that it's about 100 feet where these things cap out. Okay. So that's the reason why I missed them.|||我明白了。只有在一个特定的高度区间内，这些设计才能发挥作用。它们必须足够高，这样你就不会在一楼或二楼直接自己逃出去；但又必须足够低，以便消防员的云梯能够得着你。是的，完全正确。根据我阅读的规章制度记录（当然是通过翻译和二手资料），这些标志的上限高度大约是100英尺。好的。这就是我错过它们的原因。
Because it's within 20 feet to 100 feet. Yeah, totally. And they're really, I mean, quite small. So unless you're looking for them, they're easy to miss too, right? And you know, this actually all kind of led me back to this little journey of discovery that I took when we first met, which was over a decade ago
Because it's within 20 feet to 100 feet. Yeah, totally. And they're really, I mean, quite small. So unless you're looking for them, they're easy to miss too, right? And you know, this actually all kind of led me back to this little journey of discovery that I took when we first met, which was over a decade ago|||因为它们位于20英尺到100英尺之间。是的，完全如此。而且它们真的，我是说，相当小。所以除非你在特意寻找它们，否则它们也很容易被忽视，对吧？你知道的，这实际上让我回想起了我们初次见面时经历的那段探索之旅，那是十多年前的事了。
now, if you can believe it. I mean, I can believe it. It's been a while. I can't imagine the show before you. So it's one of those things. So what did it remind you of though? Well, we had this lunch together in Oakland and and we were walking around, and you pointed out this little black box next to a building entrance, and then another and another and so on. And they all had these little red reflective stripes. And those are, of course, Knox boxes, which you've talked about a couple of times.
now, if you can believe it. I mean, can believe it. It's been a while. I can't imagine the show before you. So it's one of those things. So what did it remind you of though? Well, we had this lunch together in Oakland and and we were walking around, and you pointed out this little black box next to a building entrance, and then another and another and so on. And they all had these little red reflective stripes. And those are, of course, Knox boxes, which you've talked about a couple of times.|||如果你敢相信的话。我是说，我敢相信。已经过去一段时间了。我无法想象没有你之前的节目。所以这就是其中之一。那它让你想起了什么呢？我们在奥克兰一起吃了午饭，然后在周围散步，你指着建筑物入口旁边的一个小黑箱子，然后又是另一个，接着又是一个，诸如此类。它们上面都有一些红色的反光条。这些当然就是诺克斯密码箱（Knox boxes），你之前在节目里提到过好几次。
And if you don't remember those episodes or didn't read the book that Kurt and I co-authored, those contain a set of keys for the building building and then all those Knox boxes are held by firefighters. So if there is a crisis, they can open up this box, therefore have all the keys to the building and then get in and out more easily. Yeah, exactly. And so you were there for me 10 years ago, drawing my attention to something and then
And if you don't remember those episodes or didn't read the book that Kurt and I co-authored, those contain a set of keys for the building building and then all those Knox boxes are held by firefighters. So if there is a crisis, they can open up this box, therefore have all the keys to the building and then get in and out more easily. Yeah, exactly. And so you were there for me 10 years ago, drawing my attention to something and then|||如果你不记得那些节目，或者没读过我和库尔特合著的那本书，那些箱子里装着大楼的一套钥匙，而所有这些诺克斯密码箱都由消防员掌控。因此，如果发生危机，他们可以打开这个箱子，从而拥有大楼的所有钥匙，进而更轻松地进出。是的，完全正确。所以10年前你在我身边，把我的注意力吸引到某个事物上，然后。
filling in the backstory. So this is me returning the favor. Well, that was fun, Kurt. Thank you so much. Yeah, thank you, Roman. Up next is actor and frequent 9iMPI contributor, Gillian Jacobs. Hey, Gillian, welcome back.
filling in the backstory. So this is me returning the favor. Well, that was fun, Kurt. Thank you so much. Yeah, thank you, Roman. Up next is actor and frequent 9iMPI contributor, Gillian Jacobs. Hey, Gillian, welcome back.|||补充了背后的故事。所以现在轮到我投桃报李了。好吧，这真有趣，库尔特。非常感谢。不客气，谢谢你，罗曼。接下来是演员兼9PI节目的常客吉莉安·雅各布斯（Gillian Jacobs）。嘿，吉莉安，欢迎回来。
Thanks so much for having me, Roman. It's great to have you back. So what do you have for us today? Well, I wanted to talk about a very particular and peculiar movie. Roman, have you ever seen the film, Scent of Mystery? No, but I like the way you say, Scent of Mystery. I feel like it can only be said like that.
Thanks so much for having me, Roman. It's great to have you back. So what do you have for us today? Well, I wanted to talk about a very particular and peculiar movie. Roman, have you ever seen the film, Scent of Mystery? No, but I like the way you say, Scent of Mystery. I feel like it can only be said like that.|||非常感谢邀请我来，罗曼。很高兴你能回来。那么你今天给我们带来了什么？嗯，我想聊一部非常特别且古怪的电影。罗曼，你看过电影《神秘的气味》（Scent of Mystery）吗？没看过，但我喜欢你念《神秘的气味》这个名字的语气。我觉得这个名字只能用那种语气读出来。
So tell me more about Scent of Mystery. Well, no judgment for never having heard of it because it's a very obscure movie from 1960. But as you may be able to deduce, it is a mystery film about a mysterious woman in danger. It has Peter Laurie, wine barrels, Spain, bad Spanish. Señor, por favor, young lady, in a big hat, muchos sombreros, uh, dandy.
So tell me more about Scent of Mystery. Well, no judgment for never having heard of it because it's a very obscure movie from 1960. But as you may be able to deduce, it is a mystery film about a mysterious woman in danger. It has Peter Laurie, wine barrels, Spain, bad Spanish. Señor, por favor, young lady, in a big hat, muchos sombreros, uh, dandy.|||那就多跟我讲讲《神秘的气味》吧。好吧，没听过也没关系，因为这是一部1960年的冷门电影。但正如你大概能推测的那样，这是一部关于一个身处危险中的神秘女人的悬疑片。里面有彼得·洛尔（Peter Lorre）、酒桶、西班牙、糟糕的西班牙语。先生，拜托，戴着大帽子的年轻女士，许多帽子，呃，花花公子。
Uh, the reason I want to talk to you about it today is because my friend Joan saw it when it first came out in theaters and is still talking about it because of something unique about scent of mystery. So what do you remember about that day and about the movie? Okay, so much about the movie. I think we got popcorn because, you know, this was a big event for us to go downtown. So back in 1960, when Scent of Mystery first premiered, Joan was a kid living in Chicago, and it turns out she and her siblings were part of a very small group of moviegoers who got to see it exhibited in its full intended experience, which was demonstrated by this one scene in particular. So all of a sudden, as I'm sitting there, this, the main character, some chase thing is going on and the main character all of a sudden goes into a flower market and this gush of sweet smell comes in our face and neither of us can breathe and of
Uh, the reason I want to talk to you about it today is because my friend Joan saw it when it first came out in theaters and is still talking about it because of something unique about scent of mystery. So what do you remember about that day and about the movie? Okay, so much about the movie. I think we got popcorn because, you know, this was a big event for us to go downtown. So back in 1960, when Scent of Mystery first premiered, Joan was a kid living in Chicago, and it turns out she and her siblings were part of a very small group of moviegoers who got to see it exhibited in its full intended experience, which was demonstrated by this one scene in particular. So all of a sudden, as I'm sitting there, this, the main character, some chase thing is going on and the main character all of a sudden goes into a flower market and this gush of sweet smell comes in our face and neither of us can breathe and of|||嗯，我今天想跟你聊聊它的原因是因为我的朋友琼在它刚上映时去电影院看过，而且直到现在还在津津乐道，原因就在于《神秘的气味》有一个独特之处。那么，你对那一天和这部电影有什么记忆？好吧，关于这部电影的记忆太多了。我想我们当时买了爆米花，因为你知道的，去市中心对我们来说是一件大事。所以在1960年，《神秘的气味》首映时，琼还是个住在芝加哥的孩子，后来得知她和她的兄弟姐妹是非常幸运的一小撮观众之一，得以体验到该片原汁原味、设计完整的观影感受，这在一个特定场景中表现得淋漓尽致。所以正当我坐在那里的时候，突然间，这个——主角正在经历某种追逐戏，主角突然走进了一个花市场，一股甜美的气味扑面而来，我们俩都快喘不过气来了，当然。
course I had to rush over and get away from the smell. A gush of sweet smell. I'm not sure what word in that phrase I find the most objectionable. What kind of smell are we talking about here? So as it turns out, what Joan was experiencing in that movie theater was smell-o-vision. Roman, what do you know about smell-o-vision? I mean, not much other than the name. I'm sure it has something to do with the technology that allows you to smell a movie as you're
course I had to rush over and get away from the smell. A gush of sweet smell. I'm not sure what word in that phrase I find the most objectionable. What kind of smell are we talking about here? So as it turns out, what Joan was experiencing in that movie theater was smell-o-vision. Roman, what do you know about smell-o-vision? I mean, not much other than the name. I'm sure it has something to do with the technology that allows you to smell a movie as you're|||我不得不赶紧跑开，离那个气味远点。一股甜美的气味。我不知道这个短语里哪个词最让我反感。我们到底在讨论什么气味？事实证明，琼在那个电影院里体验的正是气味电影技术（Smell-O-Vision）。罗曼，你对气味电影技术了解多少？除了名字之外，其实了解不多。我确信它与一种技术有关，能让你在观看电影时闻到电影里的气味。
watching it. But I didn't think there was much more to it than that. Oh, Roman, buckle up. It was the brainchild of American film producer Mike Todd Jr. And Mike Todd Jr. was the son of, you guessed it, Mike Todd Sr., who was a hugely successful theatrical impresario and husband of Elizabeth Taylor. Oh, okay. Wow.
watching it. But I didn't think there was much more to it than that. Oh, Roman, buckle up. It was the brainchild of American film producer Mike Todd Jr. And Mike Todd Jr. was the son of, you guessed it, Mike Todd Sr., who was a hugely successful theatrical impresario and husband of Elizabeth Taylor. Oh, okay. Wow.|||但我原以为它除了这个就没有别的了。哦，罗曼，系好安全带。这是美国电影制片人迈克·托德二世（Mike Todd Jr.）的心血结晶。迈克·托德二世是——你猜对了——迈克·托德一世（Mike Todd Sr.）的儿子，迈克·托德一世是一位极其成功的戏剧 impresario（经纪人/制作人），也是伊丽莎白·泰勒（Elizabeth Taylor）的丈夫。哦，好吧。哇。
So Mike Todd Sr. was this big ideas guy who loved gimmicks and doing things on a grand scale like his hit Oscar-winning film Around the World in 80 Days. It was chock-full of cameos and stars and as you could guess, shot around the world. But then Mike Todd Sr. tragically died in a plane crash in 1958, leaving his son, Mike Jr. to run his production company when he was only 28 years old. And Mike Todd Jr. wanted to continue his father's legacy of spectacle. And in this moment of uncertainty, he remembered this technology that his father was intrigued by and had actually considered implementing in Around the World in 80 Days, this thing called SmellBrain.
So Mike Todd Sr. was this big ideas guy who loved gimmicks and doing things on a grand scale like his hit Oscar-winning film Around the World in 80 Days. It was chock-full of cameos and stars and as you could guess, shot around the world. But then Mike Todd Sr. tragically died in a plane crash in 1958, leaving his son, Mike Jr. to run his production company when he was only 28 years old. And Mike Todd Jr. wanted to continue his father's legacy of spectacle. And in this moment of uncertainty, he remembered this technology that his father was intrigued by and had actually considered implementing in Around the World in 80 Days, this thing called SmellBrain.|||所以迈克·托德一世是一个充满宏大想法的人，他喜欢各种噱头，喜欢搞大手笔，比如他那部大获成功并获得奥斯卡奖的电影《环游世界八十天》（Around the World in 80 Days）。里面塞满了客串演员和明星，正如你所猜想的那样，是在世界各地取景拍摄的。但随后，迈克·托德一世于1958年在一次空难中不幸身亡，留下他年仅28岁的儿子迈克二世来经营他的制片公司。迈克·托德二世想要延续他父亲对宏大奇观的追求。在这个充满不确定性的时刻，他想起了这项曾令他父亲深感兴趣、并曾在《环游世界八十天》中考虑实际应用的技术，这个东西被称为“气味大脑”（SmellBrain）。
That needs some work. I know. So, smell brain was this device invented by an Austrian osmologist named Hans Lobb, and it was essentially a conveyor belt full of vials containing smell cues. And when prompted, the smell brain would pump the scent cue to each seat in the theater individually using a series of tubes. So it was like this synced smell experience matching what was on the screen. Exactly. Mike Todd Jr. remembered the smell brain and lob and thought, okay, I'm going to invest all of my money and the resources from my dad's production company because what moviegoers really want is to smell the movies. And this is with no market testing to support it, just the firm belief people would be so
That needs some work. I know. So, smell brain was this device invented by an Austrian osmologist named Hans Lobb, and it was essentially a conveyor belt full of vials containing smell cues. And when prompted, the smell brain would pump the scent cue to each seat in the theater individually using a series of tubes. So it was like this synced smell experience matching what was on the screen. Exactly. Mike Todd Jr. remembered the smell brain and lob and thought, okay, I'm going to invest all of my money and the resources from my dad's production company because what moviegoers really want is to smell the movies. And this is with no market testing to support it, just the firm belief people would be so|||这名字还需要改进。我也觉得。所以，“气味大脑”是由一位名叫汉斯·洛布（Hans Lobb）的奥地利嗅觉学家发明的装置，它本质上是一个装满盛有气味线索的小瓶的传送带。当收到指令时，“气味大脑”会通过一系列管道将气味线索单独输送到影院里的每个座位上。所以这就像是一种与银幕内容同步的气味体验。完全正确。迈克·托德二世想起了“气味大脑”和洛布，心想：好吧，我要把我所有的钱以及我父亲制片公司的资源都投进去，因为电影观众真正想要的是闻到电影的味道。而且在没有任何市场测试支持的情况下，仅仅凭借坚定的信念：人们会。
excited by the idea of sniffing stuff while watching a movie that they would rush to theaters. Well, history is made by dreamers, so go for it. Absolutely. So, Mike Todd, he's a marketing guy. So he decides to rebrand SmellBrain with a more attention-grabbing name, Smell-O-Vision. And he decided the way to debut this Smell-O-Vision technology was to produce and self-finance the first and only film made with the smell cues in mind during production, Scent of Mystery. Yeah, yeah.
excited by the idea of sniffing stuff while watching a movie that they would rush to theaters. Well, history is made by dreamers, so go for it. Absolutely. So, Mike Todd, he's a marketing guy. So he decides to rebrand SmellBrain with a more attention-grabbing name, Smell-O-Vision. And he decided the way to debut this Smell-O-Vision technology was to produce and self-finance the first and only film made with the smell cues in mind during production, Scent of Mystery. Yeah, yeah.|||对在看电影时闻东西这个主意感到如此兴奋，以至于会蜂拥至电影院。好吧，历史是由梦想家创造的，那就放手去干吧。绝对如此。所以，迈克·托德是个营销出身的人。因此，他决定用一个更吸引眼球的名字“Smell-O-Vision”（气味电影）来重新包装“SmellBrain”。他决定以这种方式首次推出“Smell-O-Vision”技术：制作并自筹资金拍摄第一部也是唯一一部在制作过程中就将气味线索考虑在内的电影——《神秘的气味》。对，对。
The title is extremely on the nose. Bah bah. Oh, sorry. I actually didn't mean that. Okay, okay. So what was different about the film Scent of Mystery from other films? Like how did it showcase the smell-o-vision technology?
The title is extremely on the nose. Bah bah. Oh, sorry. I actually didn't mean that. Okay, okay. So what was different about the film Scent of Mystery from other films? Like how did it showcase the smell-o-vision technology?|||这个片名真是“极其切题”（on the nose）。（双关：on the nose既有切题之意，也与气味/鼻子有关）哈哈。哦，抱歉。我其实不是故意的。好吧，好吧。那么电影《神秘的气味》和其他电影有什么不同呢？比如它是如何展示气味电影技术的？
So deploying scents in the movie watching experience actually goes as far back as the silent era. So maybe a theater would show a film that had a scene at the Rose Bowl, and the theater owner would put a cotton ball soaked with rose oil in front of a fan to enhance that experience for the audience. So some audiences got to experience the smell of movies before they even heard them. Yes, but in those pre-smell-o-vision experiences, the smell cues were created by the theater owners and not necessarily how the filmmaker intended the movie to be experienced.
So deploying scents in the movie watching experience actually goes as far back as the silent era. So maybe a theater would show a film that had a scene at the Rose Bowl, and the theater owner would put a cotton ball soaked with rose oil in front of a fan to enhance that experience for the audience. So some audiences got to experience the smell of movies before they even heard them. Yes, but in those pre-smell-o-vision experiences, the smell cues were created by the theater owners and not necessarily how the filmmaker intended the movie to be experienced.|||事实上，在观影体验中运用气味最早可以追溯到无声电影时代。所以可能某个影院会放映一部含有玫瑰碗（Rose Bowl）场景的电影，影院老板会把一块浸过玫瑰精油的棉球放在风扇前面，以此来增强观众的观影体验。因此，一些观众甚至在听到电影声音之前，就先体验到了电影的气味。是的，但在那些气味电影技术出现之前的体验中，气味线索是由影院老板创造的，并不一定符合电影制作人原本希望观众体验电影的方式。
Smell-o-vision and scent-of-mystery were going to be different because it was the first time the scents were going to be intentionally embedded into the production of the film and the smells would be critical to the plot. So how does a smell-driven plot even work? Okay, so like I mentioned before, there is a mysterious woman character and everyone's trying to figure out who this mysterious woman is,
Smell-o-vision and scent-of-mystery were going to be different because it was the first time the scents were going to be intentionally embedded into the production of the film and the smells would be critical to the plot. So how does a smell-driven plot even work? Okay, so like I mentioned before, there is a mysterious woman character and everyone's trying to figure out who this mysterious woman is,|||气味电影技术和《神秘的气味》将会有所不同，因为这是气味第一次被刻意嵌入到电影制作中，而且这些气味对剧情至关重要。那么，由气味驱动的剧情到底是如何运作的呢？好的，就像我之前提到的，有一个神秘的女主角，每个人都在试图弄清楚这个神秘女人是谁。
and every time you see this mysterious woman, you would smell her perfume. So the smell of the perfume was pumped into the audience, and then that smell is key to figuring out her identity. In that scene that you just heard, you would actually smell the perfume that you saw on screen. But dear listeners, you're just going to have to use your imagination. Sorry. So Mike Todd Jr. was so convinced that smell-o-vision was going to revolutionize cinema that he marketed it as a seismic advancement.
and every time you see this mysterious woman, you would smell her perfume. So the smell of the perfume was pumped into the audience, and then that smell is key to figuring out her identity. In that scene that you just heard, you would actually smell the perfume that you saw on screen. But dear listeners, you're just going to have to use your imagination. Sorry. So Mike Todd Jr. was so convinced that smell-o-vision was going to revolutionize cinema that he marketed it as a seismic advancement.|||而且每次你看到这个神秘女人，你都会闻到她的香水味。因此，香水味会被输送到观众席中，然后这种气味是弄清她身份的关键。在你刚刚听到的那个场景中，你实际上会闻到你在银幕上看到的香水味。但亲爱的听众朋友们，你们只能发挥想象力了。抱歉。因此，迈克·托德二世坚信气味电影技术将彻底革新电影业，并将其作为一项震撼性的技术进步进行营销。
Ads for the movie read, first they moved, then they talked, now they smell. Anyway, to really try and get butts in the seats, Mike Todd Jr. convinced his stepmother Elizabeth Taylor to appear as the aforementioned mysterious woman. And Eddie Fisher, who was Elizabeth Taylor's then husband, even contributed the title track to the film, which actually did really well. title track to the film, which actually did really well. ["A Strange Excitement in the Air"] So I'm guessing since you mentioned that The Scent of Mystery was the first and only Smell-O-Vision film, the technology behind Smell-O-Vision was not a raging success. No, not at all. Sadly, no.
Ads for the movie read, first they moved, then they talked, now they smell. Anyway, to really try and get butts in the seats, Mike Todd Jr. convinced his stepmother Elizabeth Taylor to appear as the aforementioned mysterious woman. And Eddie Fisher, who was Elizabeth Taylor's then husband, even contributed the title track to the film, which actually did really well. title track to the film, which actually did really well. ["A Strange Excitement in the Air"] So I'm guessing since you mentioned that The Scent of Mystery was the first and only Smell-O-Vision film, the technology behind Smell-O-Vision was not a raging success. No, not at all. Sadly, no.|||这部电影的广告写道：先是会动，接着会说话，现在它们有气味了。无论如何，为了真正吸引观众走进影院，迈克·托德二世说服了他的继母伊丽莎白·泰勒出演前面提到的神秘女人。而当时伊丽莎白·泰勒的丈夫埃迪·费舍尔（Eddie Fisher）甚至为电影创作了主题曲，这首歌其实反响相当不错。电影主题曲，这首歌其实反响相当不错。《空气中奇异的兴奋感》所以，我猜既然你提到《神秘的气味》是第一部也是唯一一部气味电影，那么气味电影背后的技术并没有获得巨大的成功。不，完全没有。遗憾的是，并没有。
According to audiences at the time, including my friend Joan, the technology didn't really work all that great. I think I spent the entire time going, I don't Joan, the technologies didn't really work all that great. I think I spent the entire time going, I don't smell anything, I don't smell, do I smell anything? I don't smell anything. And we thought the whole thing was kind of a bust. Some of the smells were too strong.
According to audiences at the time, including my friend Joan, the technology didn't really work all that great. I think I spent the entire time going, I don't Joan, the technologies didn't really work all that great. I think I spent the entire time going, I don't smell anything, I don't smell, do I smell anything? I don't smell anything. And we thought the whole thing was kind of a bust. Some of the smells were too strong.|||根据当时的观众（包括我的朋友琼）的反馈，这项技术其实并没有那么好用。我想我当时一直在说：我没——琼，这项技术其实并没有那么好用。我想我当时一直在说：我什么也没闻到，我没闻到，我闻到什么了吗？我什么也没闻到。我们觉得整件事简直是一团糟。有些气味太刺鼻了。
Sometimes the smells came late. Sometimes you couldn't smell anything at all. And it cost a ton of money to install. So there were only three theaters in the United States running it in full Smell-O-Vision. So the film flopped and lost a ton of money. They later tried to recoup some of their losses by re-releasing the film under the title
Sometimes the smells came late. Sometimes you couldn't smell anything at all. And it cost a ton of money to install. So there were only three theaters in the United States running it in full Smell-O-Vision. So the film flopped and lost a ton of money. They later tried to recoup some of their losses by re-releasing the film under the title|||有时候气味来得太迟。有时候你根本什么也闻不到。而且安装费用极其昂贵。因此，美国只有三家影院完整地运行了气味电影技术。所以这部电影票房惨败，亏损了巨额资金。他们后来试图通过以另一个片名重新上映电影来弥补部分损失。
Holiday in Spain, sans Smell-O-Vision. I tried to watch it for journalism, but it was not good. The film's scent of mystery and the name Smell-O-Vision became a joke in Hollywood. Just another goofy gimmick that didn't work. In hindsight, that seems inevitable, but I imagine in a moment that still felt sad.
Holiday in Spain, sans Smell-O-Vision. I tried to watch it for journalism, but it was not good. The film's scent of mystery and the name Smell-O-Vision became a joke in Hollywood. Just another goofy gimmick that didn't work. In hindsight, that seems inevitable, but I imagine in a moment that still felt sad.|||即《西班牙假日》（Holiday in Spain），去掉了气味电影技术。为了工作需要，我曾试图观看它，但它确实不好看。《神秘的气味》这部电影和“Smell-O-Vision”这个名字成了好莱坞的一个笑柄。不过是又一个行不通的愚蠢噱头。事后看来，这似乎是不可避免的，但我可以想象，在当时那个时刻，感觉仍然令人伤感。
Everyone likes innovation, to move things forward. Absolutely, and to that point, even though Smell-O--vision died, the idea of it lived on in different forms. In 1981, John Waters directed a film called Polyester. For that, he produced scratch and sniff odorama cards. And you would get a cue on screen when to, you know, scratch your smell cue, which allowed you to do the smell-o-vision in a more low tech way. Spy Kids 4, father of children.
每个人都喜欢创新，喜欢推动事物向前发展。确实，而且说到这一点，尽管“气味电影”失败了，但这个理念以不同的形式延续了下来。1981年，约翰·沃特斯导演了一部名为《多脂美》的电影。为此，他制作了“气味看片”刮刮乐卡片。屏幕上会出现提示，告诉你什么时候该去刮开气味提示卡，这让你能以一种更低技术含量的方式体验气味电影。《非常小特务4》，孩子们的父亲。
Roman, have you watched Spy Kids 4? I don't know about 4, but I've certainly seen a couple of them. Okay, well, you missed out because Spy Kids 4 did their own scratch and sniff cards called Aromascope. And recently companies like iSmell and O-Phone have tried to introduce smells into computing mobile phones. And the latest and greatest is smells for video games. And it seems like people will never let go of the stream of smelling their media content. You know, I've been through different iterations of this where like, you know, 3D has come and gone in different waves.
罗曼，你看过《非常小特务4》吗？我不确定是不是第四部，但我确实看过其中的几部。好吧，那你可错过了，因为《非常小特务4》制作了他们自己的刮刮乐气味卡，叫做Aromascope。最近，像iSmell和O-Phone这样的公司试图将气味引入电脑和手机中。最新、最棒的技术是为电子游戏加入气味。似乎人们永远不会放弃闻到他们媒体内容的梦想。你知道的，我经历过这个概念的不同迭代，就像3D技术曾以不同的浪潮出现又消失一样。
And I just feel like mostly it's like we've come to the idealized form, big screen, you know, a bunch of people in a dark movie theater looking at it. Like to me, that doesn't really need to be improved very much. But are you craving Warren Gillian? I'm not craving smells. I'll say that. Fair enough. Thank you so much. Thank you.
而且我只是觉得，大部分时候我们已经达到了它的理想形态——大银幕，一群人坐在黑暗的电影院里观看。对我来说，这其实不需要太多的改进。不过你渴望沃伦·吉利安吗？我不渴望气味。我只能这么说。很有道理。非常感谢。谢谢。
99% Invisible was produced this week by Jason DeLeon, Kelly Prime, Kurt Kohlstad, Gillian Jacobs, and Vivian Leigh. Edited by Christopher Johnson and Nina Potuck. Mixed by Martine Gonzalez. Music by Swan Real and George Langford. Cathy Chu is our executive producer, Delaney Hall is our senior editor. The rest of the team includes Chris Berube, Emmett Fitzgerald, Gabriella Gladney, Lashima Dawn, Jacob Medina Gleason, Joe Rosenberg, and me, Roman Mars. The 99% invisible logo was created by Stefan Lawrence. We are part of the Stitcher and SiriusXM podcast family now headquartered six blocks North in the Pandora building in beautiful uptown Oakland, California.
本周的《99%无形》由杰森·德莱昂、凯利·普赖姆、库尔特·科尔斯塔德、吉利安·雅各布斯和维维安·莱伊制作。克里斯托弗·约翰逊和妮娜·波图克参与剪辑。混音由马丁·冈萨雷斯完成。音乐由斯旺·里尔和乔治·兰格福德创作。凯西·朱是我们的执行制作人，德兰尼·霍尔是我们的高级编辑。团队其他成员包括克里斯·贝鲁比、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德、加布里埃拉·格拉德尼、拉希马·唐、雅各布·麦地那·格利森、乔·罗森伯格，还有我，罗曼·马尔斯。《99%无形》的标志由斯特凡·劳伦斯设计。我们现在是Stitcher和SiriusXM播客大家庭的一部分，总部位于美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心上城潘多拉大厦以北六个街区处。
You can now find us on the social media site. Blue sky is definitely the one to join. We are having some fun there. You can also connect with 5,000 other 99PI fans on our Discord server, where we talk about the PowerBroker, architecture, all kinds of fun stuff. There's a link to that, as well as every past episode of 99PI at 99PI.org. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你现在可以在社交媒体网站上找到我们。Blue Sky绝对是应该加入的一个，我们在那里玩得很开心。你还可以在我们的Discord服务器上与另外5000名99PI粉丝交流，我们在那里讨论《权力经纪人》、建筑以及各种有趣的事情。在99PI.org上可以找到通往该服务器的链接以及99PI的所有往期节目。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。